All right. I think it's time for a change up.
Let's do a little spring cleaning and redecorate our solar system.
Now I know you're a big fan of the moon,
but it's so last season let's get something fresh,
something snazzier help out Europa
that I love. I apt the loop glee luck.
I know, I know the moon is a classic,
but Europa could be a heck of an upgrade. Oh.
And before you ask the trade was mutual, the moon is just fine.
So we'll just moon swap with Jupiter. What's the worst that can happen.
What secrets does Europa have in store for us?
Would Europa be the perfect addition to our night sky?
Or did we mess up really badly?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if you Roper was Earth's moon.
Europa is one of Jupiter's 79 moons.
So I don't think they'll mind if we borrow it covered by a thick layer of
ice with water beneath its surface.
Europa is the sixth largest moon in our solar system
because of its icy surface.
Europa reflects a lot of sunlight making it very,
very bright about five and a half times brighter than our moon to be
exact. And to sweeten the deal.
Europa has three essentials for supporting life,
namely water, chemistry, and energy.
Europa's water dissolves nutrients. So they can be eaten by organisms.
This means that our new moon can be used to transport chemicals
within living cells. Plus,
if we moved Europa to our current moon spot,
it would then be millions of kilometers closer to the sun.
Sunlight might just be the one missing ingredient that's been impeding any life
there from developing further. So if we relocate Europa,
we may eventually have some new neighbors.
So are you sold yet? You're not. Well,
I've already filled out the real estate paperwork.
So we're just going to go ahead and do the swap.
So imagine looking up at the night sky and seeing, well,
everything Europa would light up the night sky and
be a breathtaking site to make things even better.
There would be no negative consequences at all. The copy. Look,
I'm really not good with this whole real estate thing.
So I'm going to come clean with you.
The first inconvenience you're going to have is.
Trouble sleeping. Imagine.
A floodlight coming through your bedroom window.
Maybe you could just get some new blinds and it won't just be
you. Who's having a hard time adjusting. It's going to affect wildlife as well.
For example,
a lot of rodents hide when the Moonlight is strong to avoid becoming dinner for
predators, but with a strong continuous Moonlight,
they'll eventually be forced to go outside and into danger.
This means the rodent population will decrease rapidly and
that would affect the entire animal feed chain.
Next Europa will shake things up, but not in a good way.
The mass of our moon is one and a half times greater than that, of Europa.
This means that Europa would have a much weaker gravitational effect on the
earth. The tides of our oceans will become much smaller.
They may stop removing pollutants and circulating nutrients,
no stuff that the ocean plants and animals need to survive.
If the tides are out of whack,
it could have a devastating effect on ecosystems and lead to mass
extinctions. Okay, well, it can't get any worse.
Can it look, don't be mad,
but we may have messed up our entire planet,
but just look at how pretty the moon is. See? Yeah,
just take it in and you're not buying it. Are you.
Our moon is responsible for stabilizing the Earth's axis
without the moon's pool.
This new gravitational shift will start affecting our planet seasons
and climate.
We could be looking at a future where parts of earth hardly ever see the
sun and others never get a break from the sun.
This would affect everything. And I mean everything.
If our access became tilted too much,
we could be looking at another ice age.
Thankfully this process would be slow.
So there would be time to prepare.
The problem is we're not sure we have what it takes. I mean,
look at global warming,
just a few degrees difference can cause entire ecosystems to become
disturbed or wiped out.
And we've barely scratched the surface of solving that problem.
Maybe we should give our real moon a call and see if it'll take us back.
We were just so excited about something new and sexy that we took our moon for
granted. I miss you moon.
The good news is there are no real world plans to move our moon
swapping our moon Europa could lead to some beautiful scenery,
but at the cost of catastrophic consequences for earth.
So in the meantime, we're going to work things out with our moon.
And what, where did it go? Oh, this is bad.
This is really, really bad.
Imagine that out of nowhere, our moon exploded.
Well, that's a story for another. What if.